hey guys is this the pattern thing here
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of Game of Thrones Season
four Episode four has called oath keeper
so what's interesting about this episode
is that it's it actually didn't take
place over to many locations to pick up
the small small and it was a bit of a
slower episode especially for episode
that reveals you know mostly of what
happened good slow Joffrey's that no
it's a good slice maybe we say slow
people get offended to be like already
meeting sports like it slow good snow is
a good episode but you know they did
slow down a bit just for to let you know
let you kind of soak in a lot of yeah
that's happening so let's start off with
King's Landing which is always the place
that has the most stuff that's going
down you know it's kind of it not kind
of but it is revealed that that uh not
only did Littlefinger you know have
something to do with Joffrey's death
right he was basically working with the
Tyrells specifically Olenna Tyrell to
kill Joffrey because Olenna Tyrell tells
that story with Marjorie about about how
she got her husband leavin her daughter
advice on sex which is funny though yeah
her granddaughter swearing oh yeah that
was funny that was a great scene because
it just shows that okay this is the
reason she didn't want her to marry
Joffrey cuz Joffrey was a bad Elena's
taking off she's going back to
Highgarden oh because she knows yeah you
know getting hot it's gonna heat it she
just needs to get out well yeah shits
gonna go down oh she's you know she
might be implicated later on who knows
what's gonna happen what's gonna be
revealed but still she yeah with
Marjorie she basically says look you
need to seduce the new King Tommen is
that his name comma in the atomic
because otherwise we're gonna lose like
all this you know all the kind of things
that they had set up and as a young male
going through the stages who wouldn't
like to have a beautiful 20
something-year-old visit your chambers
every night you know i love the kids I
don't know the acted very well he we
haven't really seen much of him but I
think did a good job it was nice when
she was talking it's weird because no I
don't know how he is is not the Act have
no idea hold the actors
but he seemed so much young yes but he
seems like a little kitty that's why
that's why he she kisses him on the
forehead right that have been a little
bit weird I think either were look too
far but I love his reaction when she
said you want me to come see you again
and he's like yeah yeah like come back
and visit me um I'm guessing he supposed
to beat what the characters so see what
1230 right yeah the actor to do the via
he looked like yeah he's a kid he's
definitely a kid he did a good job
either did good I mean he was good that
was a great scene and going back to talk
about Littlefinger I loved uh you know
sounds I always sense always kind of
gets a bad rap and I like to see a
little finger was testing her you know
she was like I don't think my husband
she was Ike saying who she didn't think
who killed who and he would say why why
she kept giving answers and she was
right like you know son says not an
idiot she's may be naive to the world a
little bit but she's learning she
learned a lot of kingsland she had to
grow up fast and i think now it she's on
this boat with Littlefinger kind of
isolated and alone we'll probably see
that because a little finger i love that
reaction he had to her which is like
what do you want and he kind of looked
at her kind of put his arm i think on
our hand on his shoulder he's like
everything i want it all basically so
he's ambitious little fingers a great
character yeah he revealed that the
necklace that they all he had she was
wearing from Dantas was was used what I
don't get though is I don't understand
the purpose of that like Elena Tyrell is
big enough where she doesn't need it you
know like have Santa I guess unless she
wants to frame her right like she could
have gotten somebody else but is she
gonna brush she could have brought the
poison in herself like the Tyrells are
not you know they're not being patted
down there's no security system and then
the wedding you know no metal detector
was going on there you know if you're
that up there in terms of you know your
highborn you're one of the most powerful
families in the whole kingdom they're
not gonna check out all your stuff you
know no so that's my only thing is I
don't I still don't understand what
unless they purposely wanted to frame
yeah sanso with the necklace and they're
not even suspecting anything with a
nickel know that this is gone his little
finger through in the ocean I think when
they were on the boat he saw like he did
you know he was a previous episode when
he you know today as sansas neck
whatever so that's gone evidence go
off that but Sansa is you know I guess
suspicious because she fled and she's
very deteriorated they thought tarian
ants ants are in cahoots doesn't really
matter cuz sir say doesn't care I mean
she just wants she sees okay it steering
why she's so angry that she's blinded
she's like oh it's tearing its sauce
I've got you know I want them dead and
Tyrion made that point when he met up
with Jamie like it doesn't matter
someone could come in their convent
confess little finger Elena Tyrell
confess with all the like the necklace
and all that stuff and say they did it
and it wouldn't matter because search
they just wanted to kill Tyrion right
that was a great see I mean I was happy
when you know Braun you know convinced
you know him to go to go visit his
brother that means every time those guys
in a room it's just great you know cuz
her she's just so bitter and drunk oh
it's nice to see Tyrion and his brother
be able to share that time Jamie
together because I haven't read the
books but from what people who have read
the books like you have told me that
that Jamie and Tyrion have a much closer
bond that you that you don't really see
in the TV show right and you see some of
that in this episode yeah but I guess in
the books they detail it out more right
yeah besides a braun and Jamie which I
think they have a cool relationship you
know brawn telling him about how like
he's like oh you talk like that like
that to my brother is it yeah I do he
got used to it but besides that we had
those nice scenes with Jaime and Brienne
yes he gives her the sword gives her the
armor tells her to go basically protect
Santa because he wants to keep his oath
right i mean i think his vows and what
what's i hope this brings people back to
nothing i mean it's a TV show you can
feel anyway one about a character its
freedom of opinion of course but i mean
i hope people you know still like Jamie
and don't hate on auntie which is a be a
lot of anger and aggression with our
last review I know it's a lot of
commenters especially geared towards me
and you may be more towards me I guess
that you know we were talking about the
whole rape scene and the director has
stated that he meant it to be consensual
yeah you know the book is consensual now
once you put something out there in an
art form it's up to interpretation
so anybody's opinion is completely valid
but he was trying not to make it seem
like a rape scene the people like hey if
she said no then that means no David no
means no David I'm like look this is a
TV show like the actors are fine there's
no like this not like really happy but I
mean in the same sense it's like the
director said this wasn't supposed to be
so it was great seeing Jamie this week
do another honorable thing I think Jamie
is trying to be better than what he is
even though he's not perfect it was nice
to him giving the armor to Bree and
giving him both keeper give me her old
keeper the new source I think he is a
good character I think Jamie is trying
to be better than what his dad is and
what his sister is he's trying his best
he's not perfect he's trying though also
within that senior yeah what did you
think I mean we got a lot of there's
some backlash look at exactly like I had
David no means no and I'm like I read a
bunch of stuff yeah and I guess it
wasn't their intent to make it no rape
that right was supposed to be consensual
I mean I'm sure there's legitimate
arguments and there's legitimate
controversy and legitimate anger towards
that scene show ever sure there were
some things like where I was at the
point where like are you mad because of
the way it's being portrayed are you mad
that it's different from the book like
right people were like upset just
because it was different from the book
right make sure sure like I'm sorry man
that's you know let's let's let's put
that aside and talk about just the scene
right yeah yeah so I mean I mean so I
said I was glad to see Jamie get a nice
moment in this episode I was max I'm
hopefully that takes away from if
they're people feeling negative towards
him because of the Circe Jamie seen you
know in the burial crypt hopefully that
all I I think they probably if if it was
something that was you know supposed to
be portrayed as consensual there there
was they should have shown I think a
little bit more yeah uh uh in terms of
the canal like they did show a little
bit of her kissing him back but it was
very like I don't know Renee was edited
together i think was editing was a
little bit off yes off i think there
should have shown a little more right i
think people get like all it's
interesting seeing some of the comments
a people got offended you no can I said
like hey I think she was kissing her
back you were like it doesn't matter if
she was kissing him back I'm like guy
we're talking about this is a TV series
I'm not analyzing a court case where
some horrible some horrific thing happen
you know this is a TV series are actors
this is a script they go home with the
end of the day there's no like foul play
going on it's like it's a TV series I
mean so at the same point it's like it
was very interesting here at all the
hostility but after this week you don't
really hear that much people seem to
really like this episode and all the new
twists and turns so besides sending
breanne to protect Sansa he's sending
Podrick to that was a great thing I love
scene projects grin on his face he was
just so happy like this so you know it's
happy to be involved oh yeah cuz he has
something to do right not now he's not
gonna get killed at King's Landing right
I thought the funniest scene is when he
called Bree answer yeah he's like oh
yeah lady my lady it was great it's like
he'll slow me down the OL ooh yeah he
was great I'm bought we'll see more pod
then that's good so I was justing to
with this episode it kind of took a step
oh no I want takes a step away from the
books but it took a step in a direction
that I don't think none of the book
readers have seen yet because we know
that george RR martin has had meetings
with Benioff and Weiss they know the
ending of the story so whether mr.
Martin finishes the books or not they
know where it's going also so that they
may go off in I know Rafi so you know
we're here at think here was now with
IGN commented that you know they've had
meetings where they said they might go
away from the books a little bit so that
was great that's why I love that so
let's start off with not the ending but
start off with a brand and his
adventures because you know things
happen in the book the whole Craster's
keep thing I didn't see coming I know
they're gonna go to Craster's and talk
to the mutineers OSI was really
interesting I was like oh I didn't know
this was gonna happen so and stuff like
that happens like in The Walking Dead or
something I'm I've no idea was gonna
happen so what do you what did you think
I know you know you read the books what
did you think I thought the brain isn't
my favorite story line and people have
said that oh because in the book it's
much more in depth and much more
interesting but in this you know I
haven't read the books remember yeah TV
show historian is just not that
interesting acer's they don't dedicate
much time to it what I do like is that
they're combining it with Jon Snow
storyline which is more interesting
right and so I like that now Jon Snow is
heading towards Craster's keep with his
you know people and and that brain is
their hostage and they're gonna be some
sort of standoff
yeah which I have no idea was gonna
happen I think that's great which is I'm
down with something like well what's
gonna happen here so give me something
to kind of look forward to and we also
see that Roose Bolton's man has come in
it's like a double agent yeah is trying
to be part of the Nights Watch right and
butting up to Jon Snow like he's like oh
yeah it was either for like a day dude
therefore day he's going on the secret
mission and he's saying his vows I'm
like den he had such a fast train and he
was there quick you gotta train it's cuz
he already knows how to fight I think
probably a lot of people i know myself
included kind of forgot about the
mutineers you know kind of put about all
these guys it's like oh yeah there's
people up at Craster's keep that you
know the killed you know the Lord
Commander and all that stuff but like
women really focused on them since that
scene happened so it was interesting to
to see those guys again I'm like oh yeah
there's that guy the one you know got
the beer and the other guy who's been a
Pacific Rim was awful yeah he's saying
it was like he's like the leader of this
great who was given to be the most fear
yeah so that was interesting so it's
nice to see those guys again and John
again off on Johnson off on the secret
mission I have no idea what's gonna
happen I think that's really interesting
so I'm I like I like that I like that
they're kind of playing with a story a
little bit i mean i'll be curious to
other people think but i enjoyed it so
then you know looking at the the last
part of the episode again kind of
veering off from the books or maybe
something that's going to be written in
the books i mean again to quote our
former you know colleague Roth cornet
you know did actually a special today a
video about the you know is Game of
Thrones spoiling the books now the TV
series now granted these books have not
been written so I have no idea I have no
answer to that question but what I did
like seeing is as soon as you saw that
the white Walker take the baby and start
walking or you know sorry riding on his
horse sounds like where's this going and
then he's guy see that little like out
of it's an ice fortress or something
Barry look like the Ice version of
Stonehenge right I was like the night
ranger whatever and dropping the baby
off now again this is all speculation
I'm just type otha sizing here I don't
know if that was maybe a hierarchy like
you don't think of like alien races like
it seemed like those White Walkers a
little bit more put together their faces
were a little more I don't want to call
them elegant look II like it look quite
as zombie ish as the other ones and I'm
like maybe they're the elders oh I don't
know I'm making stuff up but it was
interesting like seeing the day we then
touching the baby on the cheek and then
baby's eyes to transform transforming so
like I'm like who are those people is
how they get new you know how White
Walkers right like the non zombie
version right and what I'm curious is
because we know that Benioff and Weiss
have said they've said this that they
may veer away from the books is this
them veering away from the books or is
this something george RR martin told
them in a meeting you know about what
he's planning on writing so i'm curious
what do you think what it seemed not
knowing the books but would you think
what that is a scene in general the
whole i mean i thought it was cool i did
I don't think is at least for me maybe
it was for the people who read the books
it wasn't as momentous for me you know
because I just see okay he cares a baby
take my blah blah like so like you know
the music like and like so when it ends
like I'm not going oh my god right yeah
right I'm just like okay cool yeah you
know right I want another hour of Game
of Thrones right basically it wasn't
like a for me a cliffhanger or something
like I'm like oh my god right a run and
tell people did you see that last no it
was as big as like yeah Joffrey's Yeah
Yeah Yeah right so it's more of a wait
and see and also you know with the White
Walkers I'm also taking a wait-and-see
approach to them because you know most
of the stuff I'm very interested in is
is kind of the political stuff that's
happening with kingsland yeah and even
some of the more supernatural stuff
let's say the Dragons with with Daenerys
that does have a political even though I
know it's a supernatural stuff I mean
she wants to come from across the snare
oc2 like right right you know let's see
how well receive she is can she get
armies her army and you know all that
stuff so the white Walker stuff isn't as
compelling to me yet maybe when they
start coming down and trying it like
breach the wall right yeah more exciting
yeah who knows you know with with Mance
Rayder art is mana either gonna team up
with the Nights Watch the rest of
Westeros fight the White Walkers it's
not like he it's not like he's in
cahoots with them I have a feeling and
this is just again a guess but I've a
feeling since this is what episode force
we're almost halfway there we may even
get before they of the season a full
scene with the White Walkers not just
hints maybe not like telling us
everything that maybe we'll see you soon
as I'm talking communicating somehow so
I'm like that scene was pretty revealing
to the sense like okay there's a
your picture than just a bunch of frozen
people like zombie looking people
walking around there's like I mean look
like some kind of council there was like
what looks like 12 bunch of lined up
with like all black and and it looked
like their structure there's a you know
a hierarchy so I'm curious to know more
about that but again like you said it's
not really a big cliffhanger because
touch of babies I turns blue it's like
what does that mean then also we have
dinners this was actually the beginning
of the episode he had grey worm you know
no english and then them giving the
weapons to the slaves so that they can
fight and revolt and the kind of you
know they did a little scene i know i
had talked to to some people like John
snappy told me that he kind of got upset
at that one sequence because they you
know how like this this whole mirror in
place and they speak our language right
and no one speaks english but then
written on the on the walls in english
yeah kill the master it didn't bother me
that much just because i think i'd seen
that sequence in the trailer so much
yeah you see the guy getting surrounded
by all the slaves yeah and with the kill
the master and stuff that I guess I
forgot about that idea was you know
already just anticipating that scene
right and then we got to see more of
like Danny's kind of Khaleesi side in
the science of she didn't want to give
mercy to them she's like oh we got a row
respond with the injustice with justice
which I think in this world of Game of
Thrones that's how you win that's yeah
that's like a very Tywin Tywin would do
something like that yeah you don't want
to do anything like if it was Ned Sarkis
like oh ok well just write it will put
him in jail and it uh you know mercy
gets you killed that your Thrones a lot
of bad stuff happens to people when they
have mercy or trusting forgiveness and
all that stuff so yeah she's like no
we're gonna can she tack them up you
know chris i buy them in a similar way
as the children crying and yeah i
thought that was cool this is the first
time that we've seen her use kind of the
Targaryen flag oh yeah up again on the
pyramid yeah time on the top because you
know even though she is Targaryen she's
the last one mhmmm she isn't exactly you
know 22
proud of the Targaryen snow because the
Mad King you know and all that the Mad
King and then also her brother yeah very
cool to her and and so I guess maybe
she's now kind of adopted it it's more
like she's mother of dragons that seems
to be more the title she likes to go to
his didn't eres mother of dragons this
call her mother all the time I think she
likes that title better yeah yeah and
she's become kind of a messiah like yeah
figure almost bigger than 3 name yeah
freeing the slaves people adore her and
love her and I hope we get to see some
of those consequences of you know when
people are so beloved and think you're
so perfect and all that stuff and and
then you know everyone has faults so I'm
hoping to see this certain problems come
up later on for her right yeah I cuz I
mean Daenerys she's very naive and a lot
of ways she always thinks like oh I'm
gonna sail west and we're gonna love me
they're gonna clamor for me and it's
like I love the girl gives a [ __ ] about
ya Georgia said like I really a year or
two ago what was season two ago we said
like people want like you know a home
safe home their kids to grow up you know
like they want it's like politics in
America like I mean in any just like
we're not i mean granted there is you
know not to get political but there is
you know there's some propaganda and
stuff like that like that i can get
negative but i mean the most part people
just want to feel safe to some degree
you know and i think shes he thinks
she's buying into her own messiah stuff
which is a little bit you know might let
her down who knows me knows what's gonna
happen alright guys so that's what we
thought of this episode of Game of
Thrones oh forgot to mention a my
favorite new character this episode sir
pounce then yeah as a cat yeah that's
cat good old time yeah that's on oh yes
her palace cuz it what's the Navy said
my brother wanted his skin it happen
like strands brainerd yeah oh that's
awful yeah well we all knew what you
know kind of person job right that's
what's interesting about the Tomlin and
and Marjorie and Tywin and sir saying
just like that whole dynamic because
it's totally changed now because
Joffrey's dead right yeah do you have
someone that actually can be controlled
so who's gonna control them right
Joffrey was like he was a loose cannon
you know
didn't know what was gonna go on no he's
crazy yeah so yeah alright guys so
that's what we thought you can post
accountable on the website pink hero.com
or on our youtube channel think hero
make sure to subscribe to that you guys
come check us out on twitter talks of
dentists myself about anything Game of
Thrones I favorite TV shows your watch
and we're at think hero i'm at griffin
de we also have a Facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure like that page and share our videos
on Twitter Facebook and all that stuff
you